the taliban has formed a new government
in afghanistan and big surprise it is
filled with terrorists
and sorry not a single female among them
it's so sexist their incoming cabinet
includes four jihadis released from
gitmo by the obama administration in
exchange for u.s army deserter beau
bergdahl back in 2014.
gee who could have predicted this
disastrous outcome
most of the people that are in um
uh gitmo maybe they were picked up in
afghanistan but they've been picked up
all over the world they're terrorists
they're enemy combatants they're not
prisoners of war so basically what you
have is a catch-and-release game with
maniacs it's okay to let them go but you
got to kill them when they get out of
there because they're going to come back
it's absolutely it's insane
oh is that gorgeous truth-teller then
there's the taliban's new interior
minister he's wanted by the fbi with a
10 million dollar bounty on his head and
he is believed to be holding at least
one american hostage and this after
saying just yesterday there was no
hostage-like situation with the taliban
stopping americans from leaving
secretary of state anthony blinken is
now changing his tune
as of now
the taliban are not permitting the
charter flights to depart
they claim that some of the passengers
do not have the required documentation
those flights need to be able to depart
and we will work every day
to make sure that they're able to do
that
we will continue to press the taliban to
allow the charters to leave
you know dana i love how the state
department was surprised and dismayed
that it was an all-male cabinet it's
like they expected the you know a
brochure on diversity from a local
college and it was and then the
statement that said we're very
disappointed they're very concerned like
strong letter to follow yes
if they thought they were going to be
more friendly that's like getting high
on your own supply if you know what i
mean i bet you do know what you mean
dana yesterday you brought up the point
that we have to ban the phrase the world
is watching like the world is averting
its eyes right because now what's the
world going to do when these uh
characters put together their government
that not only do they have the detainees
from the bo bergdahl exchange but they
also um have invited some uh countries
to the ceremony and the countries are
russia china and iran
wow and so
yeah that's happening that's amazing we
weren't even asked
i don't
i don't know if we were on the list
maybe um and i also feel
that with um secretary blinken's
comments there one we talked about this
semantics over the word hostage
yesterday right and at this point i'm
like okay so there are people that can
come to america they've got their
paperwork might be american citizens
amongst the group also people who helped
americans and the taliban won't let them
go
to me like that's the death if you look
up in webster's yes that is the
definition and
i think he's a soft-spoken person
uh it would be nice to see a little fire
and a little determination that yes we
are going to get the people back they
they seem like they don't know what to
do they're in a in a quagmire a word i
just came up with jessica i noticed in
the new cabinet not a single trans
individual
what what what have you to say about
this what i'm most upset about about the
situation currently uh
it was kind of like you know when a new
administration comes in but they're
never actually like a new administration
because they're holdovers from the last
time there was a republican or a
democrat and this is like the greatest
hits of terrorists from the 1990s right
like people who went into bunkers
essentially
for 20 30 years and now they're back and
they're in prominent positions and dana
you run referenced uh russia china and
iran getting the invitation to the
inauguration well the rest of the world
can't come because we'll be thinking
about the lives that we lost on 9 11
because they're doing it on 9 11 which
is probably the greatest troll right of
all time um you know as we're sitting
here having this somber moment as our
allies who went to war with us
over what happened when we lost 3 000
plus americans um in one day and then
obviously you know your countless lives
since then um it's terrible it's a
hardliner
government um and the people are sitting
on these planes i don't what
what do you do i mean you're ready to go
obviously the paperwork they're lying
that they don't have the right paperwork
no one got on those flights without it
but it's government planes and then it's
also charter jets like glenn beck had a
bunch of planes that were held back he
was paying 750 000 per plane
couldn't get them off the ground a
couple days ago um it's really a
diplomatic disaster at this point yeah
it's this is it it's it's beyond belief
it's when you think about beau bergdahl
dagin i mean
you know we how we knew that was gonna
happen and now it's happening now
they're in charge
that trade for a deserter yeah
um
i just astonished by the language maybe
i shouldn't be surprised by the language
that tony blinken is using that they
were dismayed that the
taliban interim government wasn't
inclusive
and he's calling them they have
challenging track records
listen the taliban is horrible and evil
and they will always be horrible and
evil there is no born-again taliban
and that's
who we just surrendered to
that the with the greatest dishonor and
now putting our americans and our allies
in the gravest danger even here at home
but this go in terms of the language
this goes to what carter did with this
soviet union clinton did it with al
qaeda obama did with iran they act like
well it you know everyone if we just
maybe hope and
not pray because that's evil right
they'll just evolve into good democrats
that if you treat them say like with
iran if you just treat them like a
normal western government then if you
treat them like britain then they will
be britain
and that just it doesn't happen
it
regular folks you always talk about the
rubes and the rednecks and the hayseeds
with love
and if you if you talk to them
we know looking at a
rogue or a reprobate that
you can't treat them like a normal dude
because they will come at you and
they will steal from you because they're
a rogue and a reprobate but these
people in the body administration don't
seem to know that about a terrorist
organization yeah
it's like dating somebody you can't
change them they're going to be a
terrorist no matter what you know jesse
when i told you that the taliban also
banned sports for girls you said now
there's something i could get behind i
couldn't
which sports sport all sports just
i think they should be able to play some
not all there you go
so if i could go back in time yes and
change one thing
what do you think that would be
i'll answer it for you
all time i would go back in time and
make sure that barack obama was never
president
i don't know how i'd do it
but here's why
it's like you killed two birds with one
stone because if barack wasn't president
then joe biden wouldn't be president
butterfly effect book was better than
the movie
think about what barack obama did in
afghanistan even i can't even help
seriously
no my friend's brother produced the
movie
[Laughter]
he's the one that surged a hundred
thousand troops into afghanistan he was
the one that nation built he was the one
that trained the afghan army he was the
one that got hoodwinked by the
pakistanis that bin laden was just
hiding there in plain sight he was the
one that sold us on all this great
progress there that was a mirage he was
the one that traded five taliban
commanders for a deserter i'm not sure
four of them are now back right
i don't know what the other one's doing
he's like assistant to the regional
commander in afghanistan and barack
obama was supposed to be the smart one
remember joe biden was the joke obama
was smart and now the joke's president
the joke's on us
how stupid do the feds look the feds
put
trump campaign officials behind bars and
then they released the taliban
the feds
framed carter page for colluding with
the russians yet the fbi's most wanted
terrorists in afghanistan is colluding
with al-qaeda is holding an american
citizen hostage and joe biden wouldn't
even call him the enemy doesn't want to
offend the enemy
so
they're now upset there's no women in
the government there's an onion article
joe biden thinks he can me too the
taliban
world is watching who's the world the
muellers don't have women in the cabinet
do the saudis have women they're
concerned blinken i mean blinking
anthony where's the h maybe that's why
he lacks the fire there's no h
instead of being so concerned about the
gender of the taliban cabinet be
concerned about stranded americans look
you know
i was just going to say it's a biden
doesn't like the taliban because it's
hard to sniff hair under a burqa oh greg
that wasn't the reputation i was looking
for i know we have very limited time
there was a lot of stuff that just flew
out of jesse's mouth so if you could go
back in time and you could undo one
thing i sincerely doubt that that would
be making barack obama president
it'd be the first thing i get to some
other stuff out there okay the surge is
widely looked upon in in all political
circles actually as being one of the
most successful parts actually of the
war on terror in iraq but that was in
iraq
not necessarily in afghanistan okay well
there are we'll get other people on the
show to talk about okay we have to go
but basically everything that you said
was kind of absurd
this might have been the best discussion
ever about afghanistan like in the
history yes hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else